I'm mark broker I'm coming pre-recorded
so I can answer your questions are live
in the chat box during the during the
presentation today I'm going to be
talking about our paper on firecracker
which is lightweight virtualization for
SuperVeloce applications I'm gonna cover
what is firecracker why we built
firecracker some of the performance
figures that we got when we tested
firecracker and some of the challenges
we see for the future of research in to
ensure lightweight virtualization and
virtualization for service applications
firecracker is an open-source vmm a
virtual machine monitor that is
purpose-built for creating and managing
secure multi tenant container and
function based services let's talk a
little bit about how that fits into the
virtualization stack there are obviously
many ways to architect a virtualization
solution but within the firecracker
world we built on top of Linux is KVM
this is a feature the kernel virtual
machine is a feature in the Linux kernel
that allows us to build virtual machines
using a standard API right we say the
kernel start us a virtual machine and
and then the kernel handles the heavy
lifting of virtualization on the
platform I handles all the hardware
details handles page tables and and some
of the other low tricky low-level
details firecracker sits next to kayvyun
running there on top of the host kernel
and provides
firstly it does setup of KVM and talks
to the kernel and says you know set up
this this VM for me and does the i/o
virtualization and so it handles block
i/o and handles networking and so on we
built fire
crackers starting with a branch of cross
V M because we were specializing for
server lists and specializing for these
lightweight cloud workloads we started
off by removing about 50% of the code of
cross V M so this was taking out a lot
of stuff in that code base that we
didn't need all the cross VM was already
quite small and so what we ended up with
at the end of this was something that
was about I 96 percent fewer lines than
qmu 4 percent of the size of qmu which
is the standard vm m that folks tend to
use in this kind of architecture fire
cracker has a simplified device model
and what that means is there's no bios
it boots the Linux kernel directly
there's no PCI so there are no kind of
virtual PCI devices the kernel talks
these protocols of vertigo Nets and
vertigo block and so on directly and so
there's a great deal of simplification
there and a great deal of simplification
both of the guest kernel and off of the
vmm firecracker supports both linux and
os v guests our our deployment in in AWS
is is with Linux guests and the OS v
microkernel also boots really quickly
and impressively on firecracker
we've integrated and worked with the
open-source community to integrate
firecracker with the container ecosystem
there's fire cracker support in or going
into cards or containers there's a fire
cracker integration into kubernetes
called fire cube and fire cracker
integration in container D and what
these do in the container ecosystem is
allow you to replace the standard Linux
container type isolation mechanism with
this much stronger isolation mechanism
provided by virtualization fire cracker
is available with open source I it's on
github there's the same code that we ran
in production in AWS under the Apache
2.0 license and
we invite the community to take part
contribute both code and and and pull
requests and so on and are following a
completely open-source development model
firecracker is in production today in in
AWS lambda there's our service function
service in in production in AWS lambda
we are handling millions of concurrent
workloads on top of fire crackers we're
running millions of concurrent workloads
on the stack already and and that is
trillions of requests per month you know
sometimes my team jokes that we think
we've started more VMs in in AWS lambda
in the last 18 months that we've had
this in production then everyone else
has started in in the history of
virtualization such as the scale that we
use this ad so why did we build
firecracker well part of that is a story
about economics and so we ran lambda on
on a mixed on ec2 the same instances
that you can get from from ec2 publicly
and and on bare metal ec2 because we
need the the axis to be a metal to be
able to do virtualization but these m5
metal instances that we run on I have a
very big and that's that's just due to
the economics of cloud right these
things have 48 cause they had 384
gigabytes of RAM and are you know they
fit relatively normal servers but
relatively normal servers these days are
just big where's the smallest lambda
function is only 128 megabytes the
smallest function that we will let you
they will let you configure is is 128
megabytes of RAM and I can't go and buy
a server that is 128 megabytes of RAM
right like even you know embedded sort
of bras very PI's have more RAM than
that these days and so we need some way
of taking these in metal instances and
cutting the map into into many many
pieces and there was some properties
that we needed to do that in the
important property is is isolation we
want to run many functions up to
thousands so you can fit for about 4,000
of the smallest ones on to one of these
big boxes and it must be safe for these
multiple functions to run on the same
hardware and that means safe from a
security perspective our specifically we
need to be able to rent thousands of
functions on a single machine with
acceptable overheads and acceptable
densities and this is what sent us down
the path
initially of customizing virtualization
for the surveillance workload right it
was overhead and density we really
needed to you know get the great
isolation properties we get out of
virtualization but the overhead and
density of container type technology and
we didn't want to be forced into this
decision of although overhead there are
or and you know we want to both great
security and and and and and very low
overhead we also need very performance
our functions must perform similarly to
to running natively both in in CPU and
in low level things like page table
changes and in i/o and so on you know
customers of AWS don't you know don't
want to lose performance when they they
choose server list they want a serval a
solution that performs you know just
like their container solutions doing
just like their instance was doing just
like their either their legacy servers
do and so I we didn't want any
compromises on on performance we needed
compatibility the lambda product allows
customers to bring arbitrary Linux
binaries and and that's important
because it lets people bring you know
legacy code bases bring this code that
you've been building up for decades and
and trust and know about and understands
your data formats and so on and and
bring that to the cloud we didn't want
to say you know we want to want you to
be able to bring the the code that you
know in the
you have without major changes and and
even sometimes without recompiling it
and run it here in in our service
compute we needed soft allocation right
like we needed to be able to run these
many many workloads on a box in a way
that didn't commit the worst case amount
of memory and worst case amount of CPU
to each one instead
for economics what we wanted to be able
to do was take the actual amount of CPU
and actual amount of memory that each
that each workload was using at each
moment and and consume that from the
machine so instead of hard allocating
128 Meg's megabytes of memory we can go
and get memory on demand instead of hard
allocating one core we can schedule on
demand and so on and so firecracker
takes all of these boxes for us and
virtualization takes all of these boxes
for us the alternative in the
virtualization space of using qmu with
with k vm had density and overhead
challenges q mu is a great piece of
software we have human you know we work
for their community for years but wasn't
optimized for this this high density and
low overhead environment our Linux
containers which are normally the
solution or the common solution in this
space had isolation challenges and
compatibility challenges you know
isolation we didn't think the security
model was strong enough for our
customers and compatibility we we wanted
to make sure that all software I ran on
on this this platform library OS
approach is very commonly used to big
compatibility challenges there are a lot
of software is written to assume Linux
assume a particular kernel assume
there's a user land there and so on and
so these challenges are very Liberty
library oasis can be very interesting
from an academic perspective and we're
very excited about that community but
they weren't a good fit for lambda
because we wanted people to bring their
unmodified software and similarly with
language VM isolation right things like
v8 and
and Java I have these features where you
can you know create isolates within the
language VM oh we didn't like the
security model of those and we also
didn't like the compatibility because we
wanted people to be able to bring
binaries rather than just you know build
code in particular languages and you
know we were very happy with with
firecracker ticking all of these boxes
look a little bit about the performance
that we got you know one important thing
in the service world is micro VM start
time so we want to boot up we boot up a
lot of these things as we said millions
of concurrent workloads and how much
time it takes to boot one app is an
important you know important for our
ability to quickly change from one
workload to another so qmu takes about
200 milliseconds between 200 and 250
milliseconds to start up in this test
which is serial one after another and
firecracker and cloud HP which actually
shares a lot of firecrackers DNA start
up in around a hundred millisecond range
the next test and this was an important
one for us again because of how quickly
we change workloads in inside lambda was
launching many many macro vm's in
parallel at at the same time and and and
here's where firecracker really shows
are the optimization work that we've
done so in this test we launched 50
micro VMs all at the same time there 50
kind of concurrently starting up in
parallel and you can see that there's
quite a long tail on on qmu due to
contention in some pieces whereas
firecracker continues to start up in
this kind of hundred and milli second
hundred and twenty milli second range
you know right up to relatively high
percentiles and this was very important
for us and something that was a nice
outcome of the optimisation work that
the team did look Nick sit queue queue
depth one IO latency so this is kind of
serial i/o latency saying one way for it
to be done in the next month for K reads
the 4k writer
great i/o latency here
similarly with with 128 K read what you
can see there is where we're starting to
have about a 2x overhead over bare metal
so that's an overhead of about you know
about four hundred microseconds at the
four hundred twenty eight K reads and
that's mostly a bandwidth limitation but
an extra memory copy 128 K writes
similarly some overhead over over bare
metal but generally good performance and
you know performance that is is is nice
you know comparable to to local SSD
especially you know for those for those
small reads and writes and that's that's
important to as we go to QD f32 so this
is driving thirty-two parallel requests
through the i/o layer and start and this
is looking a throughput rather than
latency so here higher it's better and
you can see that that firecracker and
tout HV which shares a lot of
firecrackers code in this path perform
relatively poorly today for for K read
128 K read and this is because the
current code base is not able to handle
multiple concurrent i/o requests so ends
up serializing i/o requests in the back
end this is something we are working on
improving we we know there ways to
improve it one other interesting here is
you can see 4k writes actually faster
sorry 128 K writes are actually faster
on firecracker and this is actually in
the because of another limitation in our
IO layer in that we aren't respecting
the request to sync to disk and so those
those rights look fast because they're
going to the page cache of the host and
and and that allows more reordering and
so on and that's something else that
we're adding over time as a as I said a
feature requests here are some of the
things we learned as we rolled out
firecracker to our to our lambda fleet
operational lessons one of the things
that we sort of really baked into
firecracker and one of the things that
we think brings great value as as a
contributor
to the open-source community as we take
these lessons that we learn running AWS
and and build them into the software
that we are that we released lesson
number one is the compatibility is hard
you know relatively tiny changes like we
changed our legacy stack which was just
running on ec2 instances to to our fire
cracker base stack for lambda and on the
Firecracker side for security reasons I
that we discuss in the paper are we
disabled hyper threading and just
disabling hyper threading revealed to
concurrency bugs in Apache Commons HTTP
client and one in our own SDK code we've
we've upstream fixes to both of those
but you know very small change like
disabling hyper threading I can you know
can break code and this is one of the
things we like about virtualization we
like about booting real Linux is that
re-implementing OS components you know
implementing a library OS for example
has even more compatibility challenges
or or vastly harder compatibility
challenges and running a Linux kernel in
the guest with the code that knows how
to run on Linux is you know allows us to
to avoid a lot of compatibility
challenges and then finally performance
compatibility is important too right
like you don't want to have vastly
different performance when you move from
from the cloud - oh sorry from from an
instance or or container into the
service world our second important
lesson and this time we learned
operationally kind of running lambda and
running this feature on top of lambda is
that you we build our whole fleet on
immutable time-limited machines and your
width with a big fleet like our compute
fleet it's attractive to say well we're
going to maintain that by by using these
package management tools like rpm and
installing new versions of things over
time and what we quickly found was in
that size fleet you know small
non-determinism zin things like RPM and
d package or causing the software
versions in our feet to just diverge so
what we moved towards is we have no
machine in our fleet over a day old
we stamped them out with an immutable
image we use them as workers they host
these micro VMs for our customers and
then and then we terminate them we give
them back to ec2 and they get completely
completely reimaged and that allows us
to make sure that we have a very small
and well understood set of software
deployments in our feet which is great
for security and great for operational
sanity and then lesson three you know
this is the the the big thing from from
running the cloud is is the job is never
done you know our customers are always
asking us for new things which is
fantastic they always have new needs
there's new hardware the new you know
new requirements are and and they're
always improvements to be made and that
means that you know something like
firecracker is is always gonna be under
active development we're improving it
we're putting in investment there we're
working with open source community it's
there on github and you'll see us you
know adding new features adding better
performance and so on over time and and
that job is essentially never gonna be
done because you know the cloud is never
really done a little quick note at the
end on what we see as the future of
micro virtual or or micro VMs IO
performance and scalability continues to
be a challenge the approach of having a
software vmm means that we are currently
you know implementing virtio in software
and and you know we are have a lot of
room to improve that software and our
planning too but it's always going to be
something of a challenge and so what we
need is the i/o performance and
scalability offered by offload like we
do in ec2 with the nitro system but at
the at the same density that we need to
run serverless scheduling especially you
know at these high densities is is a
challenge around tale latency especially
as you try and drive up CPU utilization
and and I think there's some real
research opportunities there and
industrial development opportunities
we're working with the formal methods
community to to prove some more of the
security properties of fire cracker
and and be able to have you know even
more confidence in in the security of
some of the some of the paths through
that code and there's some really
interesting work that can go in on there
in into research into formal methods
they're a bunch of features that we
would like to see implemented in
firecracker some of which we're working
on ourselves already like snapshots and
ballooning but but also also lots of
opportunities for building you know more
features to - into this micro VM and one
thing I'm really excited about the space
is the rest the mmm project what we've
done with rest VM in partnership with
folks like Intel is is take some of the
core pieces of of fire cracker break
those out into a set of libraries for
building VMs in in the rest programming
language and we've already seen folks
build you know stuff like cloud HV on
top of that recipe mmm core and recipe
mmm is this this essentially growing you
know library or toolkit for building VMs
in in in rest and it's all open source
it's all available and I think it's the
beginning of something that is is really
great trend towards you know mission
mission specific you know micro VMs and
isolation and we're also excited to
continue working with the container
community to you know raise the bar for
container security for everybody
everywhere thank you I've been mark
broker I will you know be happy to
answer your questions